now fellow here you are in a British bar
with a frothy little Throne upon your
lips another plane for me friend extra
warm your accent blows well I beg to
differ
it's your drowning in the ale you're
feeling like a fail you're sorrier than
soggy fish and chips but you don't have
to sit and pout just let your inner
Scrooge come out because why should any
other jerk enjoy his day
when you're done the dumps and eat some
cheering up Seas
turn and tap our Atlas chap
and sweetly sad
good afternoon good afternoon but I
never just let one fly and you'll be
smiling pretty soon like this good
afternoon
[Music]
good afternoon good afternoon good
afternoon
I'm sensing now
so you've done nothing wrong in two very
very long and I get it's an important
point of pie it's part of my job come on
I don't stay quiet you know you wanna
try it better never let all of the
better be buckled up inside
out of the road dingus
oh come on Bob hey Scotty coming you
know you want it come on come on it's
right there
just let it's
good
afternoon
good afternoon you smell it
[Music]
back here
the words
[Music]
[Music]
wait wait was that Judy Dench oh my God
she's a National Treasure I love her and
everything I loved her in um that
chocolate Chocolat
[Music]
chocola
[Music]
good afternoon
[Music]
good afternoon
you can kiss my dick inside
Kiss it no no no no no no no oh what doc
no it's Charles Dickens it's a funny yes
thank you but there is a baby there's a
baby
madam
I am so sorry he should be
and ma'am
good afternoon
good afternoon
foreign